[Musica]
grazie grazie dell'introduzione salute
tutti come avete sentito sono qua per
parlarvi di informazione geografica
informazione geografica come un bene di
cui prendersi cura
non voglio assolutamente porre di
portarvi sui banchi di scuola non voglio
fare una lezione di geografia voglio
avesse accompagnarvi in un percorso per
capire il significato di quello che vi
voglio raccontarvi questa importanza
perché poi tutto questo diventa bene
comune e degli esempi concreti che ci
apriranno le porte in questa direzione
una delle mie riflessioni nasce da una
giornata una serata che ha avuto in
austria a innsbruck alta impostazione
neppure di pallavolo professionista dopo
allenamento mi invita un atleta della
squadra di pallavolo maschile non pub
entro in un pub
trovo un austriaco un italiano un
brasiliano non vi sta raccontando una
barzelletta
tre ragazze statunitensi
appena mi vede claudio fa coach quanti
sono i continenti come quanti sono i
continenti siete gente di sport e lo
sapete
i cinque cerchi olimpici sono cinque
però fate attenzione perché se parliamo
di terremerse se anche l'antartide
quanti atleti concetto dall'antartide i
cinque non è proprio il numero giusto
possiamo avere anche una destinazione
per quella che è ora di vedere in europa
e del piede dell'asia le americhe appena
detto americhe ho toccato il tema che
interessava in quel momento la
discussione le ragazze americane
volevo dire noi non siamo dello stesso
continente del ragazzo brasiliano e le
ho detto ok va bene però possono essere
cinque o sei o sette
l'americana per sentirmi io hard rock
tu stai sbagliando io arnott google
tu non sei google tu non puoi sapere la
verità perché tu non sei google ed è
questo il messaggio non è che mi sono
offeso per ho pensato ok l'informazione
geografica l'affidiamo a qualcuno un
oracolo che questa soluzione che mi
rappresenta con la mappa qualcosa ma la
mappa non è il territorio
la mappa non è il territorio un concetto
che ci viene da curtis chi ancora negli
anni venti dove la mappa rappresenta
soltanto una parte del territorio come
raccontare una verità o raccontare una
verità e l'informazione che vogliamo
raggiungere
e per spiegarmi meglio questo concetto
vi invito a guardare questa lettera
l'indirizzo non c'è già una mappa forse
l'avete vista perché ha fatto il giro
del mondo questa fotografia
si tratta di una lettera spedita dove i
turisti inglesi che erano dati in
islanda e che potranno ringraziare una
famiglia che si trova in un comune che
si trova a 150 chilometri da reykjavik
non conoscendole grizzo scrivono si
tratta di una fattoria in islam fatta
una persona the sun dese e lei danese
che hanno tre bambini erano tantissime
tantissime pecore sotto c'è il disegno
la lettera arrivata arrivate a
destinazione si potrebbe dire l'islanda
è piccola e abbastanza facile però
messaggio è la mappa non è il territorio
come ha ben rappresentato
lì ci sono le informazioni rilevanti per
far sì che quella lettera venga
consegnata non è tutto il territorio
quella parte necessaria per arrivare
fino a 20 e quindi se il messaggio è
chiaro adesso provate a immaginare
quando vi spostate con un navigatore
adesso se vuole spostarsi possiamo
chiedere al metodo classico informazione
all'amico funziona sempre
forse uno sconosciuto funziona non
funziona nel senso che dipende anche lo
sconosciuto che vengono davanti se del
posto non è del posto mappe segnali bene
vi voglio portare a venezia venezia
posto bellissimo siete turisti in questo
momento e volete andare dalla stazione a
piazza san marco
classico se vi vedo girare col telefono
così secondo me siete a caccia di
pokémon perché soltanto un pazzo può
girare per venezia e non ammirare quello
che c'è intorno
siete lì
iniziate a chiedere ma si chiede tre
persone su quasi tutti i turisti magari
seguito il flusso è iniziato a seguire i
cartelli e provate cartelli come questo
per san marco iniziato a fidarvi proprio
trovate cartelli come questo tutte le
strade portano a san marco probabilmente
anche perché venezia pensata per
muoversi su un suo acqua più che su un
più andrea piedi però un po di senso di
smarrimento se l'avete andate avanti le
trovate i cartelli come questo c'è
qualcosa che non torna questo cartello
no e su carta
sapete che sia una leggenda che dice che
i negozianti venezia spostano cartelli
per far sì che turisti si dovevano
davanti al loro negozio informazione
geografica in mano a terzi in questo
caso l'oracolo è negoziante che fa il
gioco di spostarvi per andare davanti al
loro negozio
un po come quello che ho fatto che io
chiamo effetto prestazione del servizio
in autogrill
andate e fate la vostra pausa uscite
dovete affrontare prosciutti prodotti
tipici caramelle cd accessori per di uno
smartphone qualcuno viene fuori
arrabbiato qualcun altro anche contempo
di questa cosa qua i bambini piangono
più delle volte perché vogliono qualcosa
di genitore non prendono però messaggio
che vi voglio dire quando usiamo questi
sistemi
queste informazioni che dice che qualcun
altro che si sta guidando che ci
assicura che l'ue l'informazione non sia
proprio quella persona ottimizzare il
percorso ma sia il modo per creare un
mercato su quello che noi stiamo facendo
esattamente come negozianti e allora
proprio questo messaggio mi interessava
portarvi di quando l'informazione mano
aperte fondazione geografica parliamo di
cartelli è un altro cartello e quelli
che mi fa morire sono quelli dell'ato
plastica questo come ha fatto impazzire
ea verona
vicolo del pomo d'oro o vicolo del
pomodoro
quando l'ho visto prima piacere stato
vicolo del pomodoro quello che c'è
scritto in alto della mela dorata
mi sembra un messaggio molto bello
perché storia no da capo mi sembra un po
di svilirlo senza voler svilire che i
pomodori e sia chiaro però quello che
voglio sottolineare è il fatto che mi
sono chiesto e non so cosa è successo
sicuramente la scritta sotto e quella
nuova perché quella decisa dal comune di
verona mi sono immaginato i momenti
all'interno del comune per decidere il
nome di questa via e ho pensato agli
abitanti che dicono al fattorino abito
in via del pomo staccato d'oro il
fattorino che magari scrive via del pomo
staccato la parola staccato d'oro e
pacchi che non arrivano i programmi che
arrivano che ci sono lì dai miei
genitori e 30 anni che più o meno già
più o meno 30 anni che vivono nello
stesso edificio con le defezioni dieci
anni fa la strada cambiato nome scelta
del comune
beh per cinque anni i fattorini
sbagliavano a portare la posta perché il
comune cosa ha fatto il comune ha fatto
giusta la scelta di cambiare il nome la
strada è aumentata all urbanistica c'era
questa necessità è uscita la delibera ha
fatto questa informazione ma la mappa
sul sito del comune non è fatta dal
comune è fatta da un'azienda che sta
negli stati uniti che metteva ancora
vecchio nome allora io produco
un'informazione io comune e poi dopo
anche il compito di segnerà la cittadini
in un tempo prima del digitale bastava
la delibera in un tempo molto più
digitale abbia bisogno anche di fornire
i dati
l'insieme delle coordinate attraverso
cui passa quella strada e visto che ce
lo possiamo permettere anche di
comunicare con una mappa cos'è il nome
di quella strada in modo che così
finalmente la posta arriva a
destinazione
dopo cinque anni con l'azienda americana
ha capito che era cambiato il nome e
tutti i navigatori del mondo ha iniziato
a portare la posta a casa dei miei
genitori
sembra una cosa sciocca però se ci
pensate
l'informazione nostra che modo di
rappresentarla da gama terza un'altra
volta e si crea qualche problema
scusatemi è un'altra cosa importante che
ci tenevo a dirvi è legata sempre la
toponomastica una cosa che mi affascina
un sacco cisco dei luoghi
anche qua a siena c'è una piazza c'è più
di un nome forse per i senesi a piazza
della posta per me che non sono senese
invece piazza marco de marco nei numeri
core dobbiamo benissimo qualche anno fa
nell'ufficio entra charles un ragazzo
americano con un forte accento da cowboy
e mi dice nabbo piazza italia dai
charles piazza italia giro il dito su
una mappa del centro storico di trento
ne individua la piazza non mi guarda
come no look e dimostra che sullo
smartphone c'era scritto da sms ci
troviamo in festa alla festa oggi alle
cinque in piazza italia non mi guarda
indica il mio dito amicie piazza cesare
battisti il nome ufficiale toponomastica
piazza cesare battisti
la gente di trento chiama quella piazza
piazza italia esattamente come lo
chiamate piazza della posta
il volantino che aveva già sera andiamo
a trovarci lì allora adesso c'è un
ulteriore informazione che quella
popolare
non possiamo raccoglierla come possiamo
creare un bene comune di tutti quanti
possono inserire queste informazioni
perché alla fine quello che vi sto
dicendo vi ho portato finora sono degli
esempi in cui l'informazione geografica
è cruciale per la vita di tutti i giorni
e che è importante che venga divulgata
soprattutto da chi la crea perché quando
in mano a terze persone possono usarla
anche per per terzi compiti poi dopo
possa essere felice di farmi il percorso
una poverina e mezzo prosciutti così
come no è indifferente questo è
importante avere questa consapevolezza
che comunque
questa informazione se giornata ma
quando diventa popolare come faccio
avere un progetto fantastico questo qua
si chiama open street map premete voi
conoscete wikipedia solitamente dico chi
lo conosce wikipedia esca dalla stanza
lo dico semplicemente perché essendo uno
dei primi siti al mondo visitati e molto
difficile che non si conosca però è
anche un rischio dire questa cosa o per
stretto come wikipedia dove le persone
raccolgono delle informazioni e
costruiscono la mappa del mondo ma
soprattutto costruiscono una base dati
un bene comune che diventa patrimonio di
chiunque e chiunque quindi può andarmi a
inserire delle informazioni può andare a
farlo ho disegnato una fotografia la
strada all edificio oppure raccogliendo
i dati così ps con lo smartphone
occorre essendo dati di altre persone e
andare ad arricchire questa base dati e
creare questo bene comune che poi dopo
diventa un bene comune di tutti e tutti
quanti possiamo lavorarci risultati sono
cose come queste da questa parte qui c'è
open street map
dall'altra parte c'è un'altra mappa
a me non interessa qual è la più bella
forse questa da questa parte si va già
meglio quello che mi interessa è la
quantità di oggetti che vedete la sopra
perché gli oggetti che vedete la sopra
sono la generosità delle persone del
tempo che hanno dedicato per costruire
questo bene comune
e questa cosa qua non emoziona tutte le
volte perché quella mappali anche sono
nel territorio è molto più vicina al
territorio perché molto più vicino alle
persone e con abbiano quei dati
succedono cose come queste che quei dati
possiamo rappresentare in maniera
diversa
fino addirittura arrivare a farlo in
acquarello c'è un'azienda americana ha
usato questi dati ha creato questa una
par acquarello una mia amica la usa come
carta da pacco a una cartoleria se
arriva anche a rappresentarli in tre
dimensioni ma vi ripeto normalmente
tutto quello che ce li hai fatto dalle
persone al contributo delle persone dal
condividere questa conoscenza
questo fa sì che non possiamo rendere
visibile ciò che è invisibile l'avete la
mappa delle fontanelle di siena
dentro ben street cioè io possa
interrogare per street mai farmi dare la
lotta delle fontanelle addirittura posso
chiedere anche dove piazza della posta
perché c'è un'informazione giustamente
piazza giacomo matteotti ma mi dice
anche che si chiama piazza della posta
la duttilità attraverso cui opero
scritto ma per raccoglie informazioni e
rende disponibili ha avuto un
grandissimo successo un ambiente
umanitario questa qui e amatrice quando
sono stato il terremoto la comunità
italiana di open street map che siamo
noi ma non noi comunità noi perché
aperta ha iniziato a disegnare gli
edifici era fondamentale avere una mappa
degli edifici prima del terremoto è
iniziato può anche servire ulteriori
informazioni
quel lavoro lì non è passato inosservato
perché a un certo punto copernicus ms
coperti così emergency system un
progetto europeo che non fa altro che
controllare il territorio europeo e
intervenire aiutare fornire dati in
situazioni di emergenza ha preso quel
lavoro e l'ha reso disponibile ai
soccorsi umanitari
quindi il messaggio con cui vi voglio
voglio concludere di salutarvi
se è vero che la mappa nel territorio è
vero che noi siamo il territorio
ciascuno di noi e fa parte del
territorio e può contribuire a questo
grandissimo messaggio grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]